it's great to welcome to the program
today Mara vishton doll who's the former
China correspondent for science and also
author of the scientist and the spy a
true story of China the FBI and
industrial espionage so great to talk to
you today mara thanks again for having
me on the show
so let's start with industrial espionage
many people not familiar with this or
may have an idea of what it means Donald
Trump notably talking about it
typically in reference to China China
treating us unfairly China stealing
intellectual property what's the big
picture of industrial espionage is it
typically involving in intellectual
property what are the sort of different
types that maybe exist yes so going
after industrial espionage from China
has been a huge priority of the Trump
administration it is one of the sensible
justifications for the trade war that he
started with China but being focus on it
actually goes back over a decade to the
Obama administration the FBI made
fighting industrial espionage a top
priority and started taking on
investigations involving technologies
like the whitener in Oreo cookies wind
turbines and even genetically modified
corn which is at the heart of my book
and on that note I mean oh so yeah if we
think of the whitener in Oreo cookies
for example doesn't sound like there are
major national security implications
necessarily but when it comes to
industrial espionage how frequently are
classified technologies involved how
frequently are government contractors or
programs and research involved there
have been cases involving national
security technologies but the government
the US government is basically been
arguing that an attack on our US
corporations and an attack on our
economic security is an attack on
national security so it's been this kind
of expansive
reimagining of what national security
means as it has become a priority when
you talk about industrial espionage is
the motivation typically a motivation of
getting an advantage when it comes to
the ability to earn a profit I mean is
that national security instances aside
is that mostly what is at issue here
trying to earn a profit by getting some
kind of technology technique product or
otherwise an element of something from
another company sure yeah Chinese
developing very rapidly or I was
developing I should say before the start
of the global pandemic yeah and there
are a lot of companies who are you know
really just interested in in short term
getting ahead at all costs
stealing technology is the most
expedient way to do that
but you know I wanted to draw attention
to whether this is the best use of our
resources
the policies that the Trump
administration put in place led to the
deterioration of us-china relations
which is now absolutely critical now
we're seeing with the pandemic that
cooperation could be essential to
fighting it and all of this back and
forth over industrial espionage really
led to the decline of of that
relationship so not that an eye for an
eye is the right or the wrong thing but
just so that we have all the information
how frequently is the u.s. doing the
same thing elsewhere the u.s. stance is
that we don't spy for the benefit
specific benefit of our private
corporations there are some people who
take issue with that who point to small
examples of it could have happened here
or there but you know in general the
u.s. is at a point in our development
where we don't need to there were
certainly points in our history where we
did take a lot of technologies even
early America there was quite a lot that
was stolen from England for example but
China's now at that stage where it is
rapidly developing and
where the you know the US has a lot of
desirable technologies I think that the
question is should an ear of corn be
treated like a national security secret
yes so let's get into that story I mean
describe the story that you tell and
highlight in the book the scientist and
the spy so I look at the case of Robert
Moll who was a Chinese born engineer who
is found in an Iowa cornfield in 2011 he
was initially suspected of trespassing
but his appearance there ended up
setting off this 2 year FBI
investigation involving surveillance
planes Airport busts and the use of a
FISA warrant which is intended to be
reserved for extreme national security
threats and what was he trying to
accomplish in that cornfield well it was
a monsanto cornfields the company
treated the next generation a hybrid
corn that was growing there as trade
secrets robert mull worked for a beijing
agricultural company that wanted to
steal that corn at one point they
actually tried to send it back to China
in microwave popcorn bags and so they
had this kind of harebrained scheme and
the FBI meanwhile decided to track them
over years bugging their cars chasing
them across the Midwest and so you had
this kind of absurd cat-and-mouse chase
that in the end was a massive use of
taxpayer taxpayer resources yes so
there's a there's so much to talk about
with regard to this I mean what you
mentioned the question of is this a good
use of FBI resources which are
taxpayer-funded
that's one debate to be had the other
question is is this another example of
corporate power and the degree to which
corporations dictate law enforcement
priorities whether you want to talk
about private prisons existing
influences
the judicial system and how the judicial
system functions should that be the case
I would argue no is that not another
underlying story here which is that
because of what who Monsanto is they
have a lot of say in what the FBI
doesn't doesn't work on oh definitely
you know so I retraced Robert most steps
i retrace the steps of the FBI agent who
is tailing him there at one point there
were seventy some agents working on the
case of dozens of people in multiple
multiple states just a massive use of
resources and you know as I was
traveling around the Midwest talking to
farmers about this case there were many
people said to me look you know Monsanto
and DuPont pioneer another company in
this in this case they have massively
consolidated over the past few years
they eat to the point where the price of
seed has gone up for many many farmers
and when you look at what the
impediments to innovation and
agriculture are that corporate
consolidation is a very big one now on
the other side of this you know it's
very easy to say hey listen there's
intellectual property here and the
intellectual property is being violated
or threatened you've got a guy standing
in a cornfield that's it's sort of
pretty cut and dry aside from whether
the FBI should be involved there only
local police or whatever that's one
question but on the other side of that
is it may be too easy to get
intellectual property protection for
things that one could debate whether
they should or should not be subject to
that level of protection from government
intellectual property infrastructure in
the sense that you know when we talk
about what can you trademark what can
you patent etc that's another side to
this story that is you know I do think
there is a big a big place for IP
protection you know I'm a writer I
believe that my work should be protected
I don't want people out there pirating
my book same with my other hat solutely
agree on the other hand you know when
you
look at what should be done to protect
innovation in this country there's also
a big role for antitrust enforcement and
that's something that has really taken a
backseat to other priorities in the past
few years but even in the Obama years
there were several big antitrust actions
that fell apart and one of them involves
Monsanto so even as the Justice
Department was bringing this case on
basically on behalf of Monsanto there
was an antitrust inquiry explored by
another arm of the department that then
fell apart
well that seems to be if you zoom out
that's the trend right which is when it
comes to allowing intellectual property
protection it by and large benefits
large corporations over small
individuals and we see that you know in
myspace we see it on platforms like
YouTube and others where the benefit of
the doubt by default goes to the large
media company and not the small producer
etc you bring up antitrust which is an
opportunity to regulate and control some
of these large corporations but again
they're it's not nearly enough used as
you're sort of pointing out so is that
the overarching story or what what is
really the overarching story here when
it comes to industrial espionage in your
mind well ultimately I was drawn to this
story because it was such a good story
it had all these twists and turns and
these interesting characters nobody was
really fully all good or all bad and
just very kind of complex and I saw that
I could structure it like a thriller but
at the same time it also tapped into all
these other themes of corporate control
of the expansion of what constitutes
national security of the FBI turning
itself from a law enforcement agency
into a counterintelligence agency which
has also played a big role in in the
expansion of what constitutes an
investigation and and so this by looking
at this one small case I could get at
all of these other issues so if we zoom
out from this case a little bit can you
give us some other types of industrial
espionage that maybe are less obvious
than the
the case we're talking about corn and
Monsanto seeds and and some of those
others that are under that umbrella what
else is included under this umbrella of
industrial espionage more broadly Oh
pharmaceuticals the insulation that's
used in walls any lot of industrial
compounds and chemicals and you know
basically if you look at the major
corporations in America and what they're
manufacturing many of those products
have been the subject of these
industrial espionage
Kait fractions this stuff can be life
and death in some cases right I mean now
when we're talking about n95 masks and
masks that are at issue when it comes to
health care workers that are treating
coronavirus patients and you know you
start hearing about rotten masks or
faulty masks masks that are called and
95 but aren't really I mean this is all
wrapped up with some of this
intellectual property is it not right
well yeah counterfeiting is a big issue
as well and I've just been looking into
that for another story I'm certainly a
big concern and that is really about the
concern over PPE and masks and where
they're coming from that's really about
global supply chain issues and that's
certainly been complicated by the trade
war that the Trump has started with
China and you know also just by the
general decline in us-china relations so
over the past few the few weeks things
have really reached a new low with China
and precisely at the moment when we need
we most need to be cooperating on this
issue so last thing I want to touch on
is as far as the trade war in the
inclusion of again trying to stop
Chinese spying and theft of intellectual
property Donald Trump very loudly said
that China is doing this he said the
trade agree that not Trade Agreement but
the trade the tariffs and the larger
package that he put in place was going
to solve that and he even recently
offhandedly said that this is something
that he has now fixed through his policy
what's the
truth of that is the policy that Trump
put in place including tariffs actually
solving this issue it certainly hasn't
it certainly hasn't helped us in terms
of sourcing medical supplies from China
because there are still some tariffs in
place but just more generally the he has
pushed us away from China things were
already bad when he came into office but
you know in by using phrases like
Chinese virus and in kind of perpetually
pointing fingers encouraging China to do
the same which they have we've reached a
really a new low point and in us-china
relations what would be a policy that
would actually work constructively to
resolve the issue of industrial
espionage between the US and China well
whatever we do we need to put in place a
policy that doesn't make researchers
feel targeted so that's another piece of
the puzzle is that there is this
perception among many Chinese American
and Chinese scientists they are being
singled out because of their ethnicity
and some of them maybe have committed
infractions but there are also cases
where people have been arrested who
turned out to be innocent and so that's
ultimately detrimental to the u.s.
innovation infrastructure if we drive
out a lot of the research force and
we're seeing that now as we try to
develop vaccines and try to develop
treatments for clova 19 that many of the
people who could be working on this are
now back in China because they've been
driven out by overzealous investigations
we've been speaking with Mara vishton
dal who is the former China
correspondent for science and also
author of the book the scientist and the
spy a true story of China the FBI and
industrial espionage mara so great
having you on I really appreciate your
time well thank you again